ich begrüße Gregor Gysi linken Politiker
rund ein Jahrzehnt deren
Fraktionsvorsitzenden am Deutschen
Bundestag jetzt außenpolitischer
Sprecher und momentan unterwegs in
Thüringen herr Gysi china will das
Schreiben sie in der Berliner Zeitung
oder sagen Sie der Berliner Zeitung will
den Ukraine Krieg unbedingt beenden
damit machen sich ja dass chinesische
narrativ der Reise auch des Friedens wie
es jetzt gerade genannt wird eins zu
eins zeigen
nein natürlich nicht mein Ausgangspunkt
ist ein anderer der generalstaatschef
der USA milley sagt weder die Ukraine
noch Russland kann den Krieg gewinnen
und ich will nicht eine Krieg wie verdur
oder der jahrelang geht und deshalb sage
ich sofort ein Waffenstillstand die
Schwierigkeit des Szenen zu erreichen
also nach Rücksprache mit der
ukrainischen Führung könnte doch die
NATO sagen gut wir sind bereit jetzt
keine einzige Waffe mehr an die Ukraine
zu liefern wenn ihr sofort einverstanden
seid mit einem Waffenstillstand das
würde Putin unter Druck setzen da wenn
er nein sagt sagt er ja liefert weiter
Wappen wenn er ja sagt wird zumindest
nicht mehr geschossen keine Toten keine
Verletzten keine Zerstörung und dann
müssen komplizierte
Friedensverhandlungen beginnen das wird
nicht mehr geben wird toll zum macron
aber vielleicht mit Luder oder anderen
oder Österreich die wirklich neutral
sind und dabei darf die Ukraine nichts
verlieren das heißt es haben damals hat
gesagt es gibt einen Unterschied Ukraine
Siegen muss oder nicht verliert da das
heißt das neue letzte Territorium muss
letztlich geräumt werden aber man könnte
doch Kompromisse finden wie doppelte
Staatsbürgerschaft und andere Sachen ich
möchte nur dass das Schießen so schnell
wie möglich beendet wird während der
Bundeskanzler jetzt erklärt hat wir
müssen uns darauf einlassen dass das
lange dauert was heißt denn das ein ein
Krieg den keine Seite gewinnen kann ich
meine es ist ein furchtbarer
Angriffskrieg Russlands das muss man
Schaf verurteilen aber ich möchte das
jetzt einfach ein Stillstand kommt so
schnell wie möglich bleiben aber noch
mal bei China hätte doch aber eigentlich
gar keinen Interesse daran dass dieser
Krieg zu Ende geht z.B beispielsweise
der Chef der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz Häuschen hat
gestern noch mal gesagt Russland ist
jetzt eine
discount-tankstelle für China und das
Schätze natürlich Ski also im Prinzip
hat man doch einen der Global Player gar
nicht auf seiner Seite und ohne China da
sind sie wahrscheinlich auch der Meinung
wird man keinen Frieden bekommen
das stimmt ohne die USA übrigens auch
nicht also das ist nun mal die Situation
ich glaube China ist deshalb daran
interessiert weil sie jetzt sowieso
Russland an ihrer Seite haben sie wollen
auch die blockkonpräsentation nicht
unbedingt verschärfen gegenüber den USA
aber sie wissen wie es ist das ist das
bevor ich immer gewarnt habe ich habe
auch mit US Diplomaten darüber
gesprochen ich habe gesagt Brix kann
jetzt zu einem neuen Block werden das
ist Brasilien Russland Indien China und
Südafrika und man hat sich darauf
verlassen dass die Widersprüche zwischen
Indien und China zu groß sind aber
wissen Sie wenn es so macht Fragen geht
dann werden kulturelle Widersprüche
beiseite geschoben und was jetzt sie
macht ist doch der Beginn auch dieser
Blockbildung und insofern sage ich wäre
es für uns auch für den besten wichtig
dass so schnell wie möglich ein
Waffenstillstand kommt und sich das
nicht immer mehr vertieft sie wissen ja
wie sich der Präsident Brasiliens Luna
dazu geäußert hat wir wissen dass die
südafrikanische Außenministerin gerade
den russischen Außenminister besucht hat
wir wissen auch wie sich Indien verhält
wir haben ja auch ihre Vorteile ich
meine Russland verkauft jetzt ist das
Erdöl an Indien und die EU also
EU-Länder verkaufen dann das russische
Erdöl von Indien nur als teurer als
früher nah auch ein genialer Streich
kann ich nur sagen also kurz um ich
mache mir wirklich Sorgen über eine
Blockbildung und deshalb bin ich dafür
so schnell wie möglich zu einem
Waffenstillstand zu kommen damit man das
eine oder andere noch reparieren kann
wenn wir jetzt noch mal vom
Waffenstillstand weggehen den sich ja
vielleicht dann viele auch momentan
wünschen kommen wir noch mal zum Thema
China und sie sind ja auch aus
politischer Sprecher der Linken wie
sollen wir denn eigentlich mit China aus
ihrer Sicht umgehen weil sie haben mal
gesagt Sanktionen gegen China oder auch
gegen Russland machen keinen Sinn haben
auch mal geäußert das war allerdings
noch vor dem Angriffskrieg Russland
gegen die Ukraine dass man dich
chinesischen Interessen nicht
ausreichend berücksichtigt hätte da
frage ich mich einfach mal
China da nicht so rücksichtslos in den
letzten Jahren vorgegangen dass man eher
das umgekehrt sehen müsste
also zunächst bei russland habe ich
nichts gegen Sanktionen die gegen
russische Führung gegen das russische
militär- und rechtsstaatlich auch nicht
gegen Oligarchen aber die russische
Bevölkerung zu verarmt finde ich falsch
weil die hat den Krieg nicht beschlossen
und außerdem treffen uns die Sanktionen
zwischen Hertha was China betrifft
wissen eben meine Erfahrungen sind
andere wie Sie wissen komme ich doch aus
der DDR und erst hatten wir die
Heilstein Doktrin also in der
Bundesrepublik wenn ein Land
diplomatische beziehungsweise der
Aufnahmen wurden alle Beziehungen zur
Bundesrepublik abgebrochen das hat die
DDR versteinert und dann kamen wir die
Brand mit Wandel durch Ernährung und hat
immer Angebote gemacht er tauscht du
noch Politik gegen Politik Helmut Kohl
tauschte dann Politik der DDR also
Veränderungen in der Politik der DDR
gegen Geld und da hat sich doch die DDR
so langsam gelockert werden plötzlich
richtig west-journalisten und
westjournalisten es wurde wenigstens in
dringend den Familienangelegenheiten
Reisen erlaubt und so und ich glaube
dass dieser Weg besser meine Erfahrung
ist bei bestimmten Sanktionen Igeln die
sich ein dann suchen sie in Ausgleich
woanders und mit anderen Ländern wie wir
das auch erleben während Angebote dass
man sagt wissen Sie wir könnten doch das
in den Beziehungen verbessern jenes in
den Beziehungen verbessern und dann
stellen wir aber die Bedingung dafür
dass sie ein Mindeststandard an
Menschenrechten gegenüber den Uiguren
waren was wir dann auch mal
kontrollieren dürfen und ich glaube dass
das mehr macht Sinn macht sonst na gut
jetzt haben wir die Sanktion beschlossen
und geht zu üben besser nee und deshalb
glaube ich das ist kein Weg außerdem
sind sie lieben zweitgrößte Wirtschaft
Macht der Welt wir dürfen das nicht
unterschätzen und ich kenne ja
US-Diplomaten die sich jetzt ärgern dass
man vor dem Krieg natürlich nicht
intensiver mit Russland behandelt hat um
den Krieg zu verhindern weil die
eigentliche Herausforderung für den USA
ist China und nicht Russland und jetzt
hat sich das alles verschoben und jetzt
fühlen die sich gezwungen China Russland
ein Bündnis einzugehen wirtschaftlich
aber auch militärisch ich glaube nicht
dass das Interesse des Westens ist und
deshalb sage ich meinen anderen Weg
versuchen so wie im Kalten Krieg also
Überforderungen zur Veränderung
Verbesserung in den Beziehungen anbieten
nicht nur Sanktion übrigens sein der
deutschen denken immer in Form von
Sanktion also wenn ich zum Beispiel ein
Hartz IV Empfänger denke wenn die nicht
zu Termin kommen gibt es eine Strafe ich
würde es umgekehrt machen ich würde mal
sagen die wirklich Kranken Hartz IV
Empfänger und die engagierten kriegen
einen Bonus Punkt und die anderen nicht
also man kann auch nach sozusagen
positiv reagieren aber wir kennen ja nur
für Vorstandsmitglieder von Konzern also
ich würde das gerne ein bisschen
Aussehen ich würde jetzt gerne noch mal
einen Einsatz von ihnen den sie in der
Vergangenheit immer wieder zitiert haben
gerne noch mal hervorheben und auch noch
mal ganz kurz von ihnen eine Einordnung
bekommen sie sagen Wandel durch
Annäherung zitieren da mit ja auch Willy
Brandt das hat doch aber wenn wir mal
ganz ehrlich sind im Falle Russland
überhaupt nicht funktioniert wir haben
selbst nach der krimbesetzung nach wie
vor beste Geschäfte mit Russland gemacht
Putin wurde nach wie vor hoch 4 von
verschiedenen Politikerinnen und
Politikern das hat nicht funktioniert
und bei Ski hat es doch auch in der
Vergangenheit überhaupt nicht
funktioniert er China setzt seine
Politik auch gerade im pazifischen Raum
im indopazifischen Raum konsequent durch
egal wie wir uns da verhalten
ja ich weiß nicht ob das stimmt also ich
bin in meinem Beispiel nennen natürlich
ist die NATO immer mehr erweitert worden
dann hat im dezember 2021 Putin beiden
angerufen hat gesagt er will mit ihm
über die Ukraine reden also das ist
zwischen uns beiden völlig klar die
beiden können ja nicht entscheiden was
mit der Ukraine passiert das muss schon
die Ukraine selbst entscheiden aber
trotzdem man hätte das Gespräch führen
müssen und weder die Deutschen noch die
französische Regierung haben
eingegriffen bei beiden gesagt hat er
redet überhaupt nicht über die Ukraine
vor dem Krieg hat dann Putin drei
Bedingungen gestellt er hat gesagt also
keine weitere Bewaffnung der Ukraine
ewige Neutralität der Ukraine und auch
keine weiteren Art wo Aufnahme daraufhin
hat die NATO dreimal höflich nein gesagt
ich hätte was ganz anderes gemacht ich
hätte gesagt oh das ist ja interessante
Forderung wir haben auch drei
Forderungen erstens keine Cyberangriffe
mehr aus Russland zweitens die
Anerkennung der Souveränität und
territorialen Integrität aller
Nachbarstaaten und drittens keine
Manöver mehr an Grenzen mehr ach so das
wollte ihn auch keine man der NATO im
Schwarzen Meer und dann hätte ich gesagt
jetzt sind wir bereits zu verhandeln und
wenn wir beide ein Stück aufeinander
zugehen könnte man eine Lösung finden
ich finde das ist nicht klug gemacht
worden man hat die Diplomatie und die
Möglichkeiten einfach unterschätzt
natürlich haben sie recht dass es auch
gute Wirtschaftsbeziehungen gab aber die
USA haben eben auch ihre Politik
durchgesetzt und wir dürfen uns doch
nichts vormachen sicherheitspolitisch
sind wir jetzt auch völlig abhängig von
den USA alle NATO-Staaten alle
EU-Staaten das mag ja ein Erfolg für
beiden sein aber auf der anderen Seite
kriegt das eben mit dem Haus
Herausforderung China zu tun und bei
China war es auch so die hatten immer
bestimmte Auffassung und dann haben wir
erstens versteht man immer schlecht
wissen Sie wenn wir ein Hafen kaufen
machen wir ein Riesenfest mit viel
brumborium und Kranz sondern die
Chinesen kaufen und sagen gar nichts
dazu denn wir merken das immer erst
hinterher ist eine völlig andere
Mentalität das muss man alles sehen ich
habe dort in Gesprächen festgestellt
wenn man sie ein bisschen grob dann darf
man sie auch kritisieren also es ist so
ein anderer Stil der Diplomatie und
deshalb sage ich nein wir haben das
nicht ausreichend versucht denn China
will ja die USA nicht beseitigen und die
USA wollen ja auch China nicht
beseitigen also muss man versuchen ein
bisschen aufeinander zuzugehen zumindest
finde ich sollten wir den Versuch
wiederholen und wir haben ihn nicht
ausreichend gemacht das sagt Gregor Gysi
aus der politische Sprecher der Linken
herzlichen Dank für Ihre Informationen
heute Morgen und auch für das was sie
uns hier heute noch mal als ihre Politik
dargestellt haben herzlichen Dank
bitte schön rauskommen
Tanja und Ramona sind alleinerziehend
sie leben mit ihren Kindern von Hartz 4
einen Job haben sie nicht denn je
kleiner die Kinder desto schwierige ist
es für Mütter Geld zu verdienen
finanziell oder sowohl als auch
[Musik]
finanziell nicht so besonders
da haben wir hier viele
kleine Problemchen sag ich jetzt mal
weil ich als alleinerziehende Mutter
komme mit dem Bürgergeld
vorher wie auch jetzt bin ich nicht
damit zurecht gekommen weil Kinder sind
teuer wie man weiß
meine Tochter ist jetzt im Moment in
einem Wachstumsschub wieder und ich
verzichte auf alles was geht eigentlich
wollte nur was ich habe ist mein Makel
das ist das einzige was ich mir gönnen
diese Wohnung wird vom sozialwirt vom
Jobcenter übernommen
wie viel Geld haben sie zur Verfügung
ich